morning John what are you doing tonight
in fact everybody watching what are you
all doing tonight watch some movies
maybe gonna see some TV scroll screw
through the infinite scroll I'm tumbler
maybe or on Facebook maybe you're gonna
catch up a little on work read a book do
some errands no I'm not gonna let you do
any of those things stead we all of us
we're gonna do a thing together and no
exceptions we are all going to write a
letter to someone who represents us in
government it's an assignment you're
watching a video and in return you're
getting homework basically if you don't
want to write a letter put a stamp on it
and put it in the mail I'm watching this
video right now because I'm gonna make
you feel really guilty if you don't do
it unless you live in a country that
doesn't have democracy in which case it
is your responsibility to make all of us
who do live in democracies feel real
guilty for not sending letters so I'm
gonna talk about how to send a good
letter to your government representative
or someone who works in your government
I'm actually writing one of my letters
by hand now of course this is not
necessary but I'm doing this because I
know that this is all about time capital
it's about value and sending an email is
easy while writing a letter by hand and
hand delivering it to the person's
office that's hard that's more likely to
get noticed and the nutty thing is these
letters actually matter
I actually had a hard time believing
this but I've talked to a lot of
staffers from congressional offices and
they agree letters matter and phone
calls matter and they matter more than
Twitter and email because they showed
that the constituent cares more letter
to a government representative should be
respectful no curse words no anger it
should outline who you are and that you
are part of the community that that
person represents you can outline how
you are a part of that community if you
wish should also get to the point really
fast if there's a way that this
particular issue is affecting you in
particular or you have a personal story
you shouldn't share that but do it
quickly and without griping outline
ideally somehow separated a little bit
from the rest of the letter what exactly
you are requesting I'm asking for a ban
on assault rifles in America and for
Congress to allow the CDC to study and
fund the study of the public health
effects of guns after a 20-year ban it's
important to understand this particular
representatives perspectives on the
issue that you care about so you know
whether to thank them for their
positions or not I've put some info in
the description for how to find
government representatives and how to
look up their voting records remember to
include your address on the envelope in
case they want to write you
which remarkably they often do actually
wrote three letters one to each of my
senators and one to my representative
the text of which can be found in the
description feel free to pull from those
or to be inspired by them but of course
make them different form letters are
noticed immediately by staffers and not
given the same weight of course your
issue could be whatever you want your
issue to be but I want us as a community
to reach out to our governments whatever
country you're in and let them know that
we care about our countries after
watching Hanna's video this week I
simply could not not do this right now
or tonight but in the next 24 hours do
this thing do it for me do it for you do
it for your country do it for whatever
you want to do it for we confine our
shouting to the Internet to Facebook and
Twitter and Tumblr and talking to other
people who agree with us you might make
ourselves feel better and feel righteous
but we are not on the path that creates
the most change so one day for one hour
instead of doing whatever you were gonna
do tonight do this things you've written
your letter if you want to share it you
can send it to me on snapchat or Twitter
or Facebook or tumblr you can use a
hashtag or a tag if you're on a place
that sports those things so you can see
other people's letters and if you see
them thank them for sending their letter
thank you for doing this I found it
empowering and a little scary but if you
not doing something that scares you
every once in a while you're doing it
wrong John I'll see you on Tuesday